Hello, and welcome to the Unreal Training Stage Operations blended learning session.
My name is Kevin Miller.
I'm one of your instructors for the recorded video supplements that are in this section.
My name is Sean Spitzer, senior instructor for Epic Games, also recording sessions
here for you guys.
So in this training outline, we're going to take a look at some supplemental videos
that are recorded as part of our live Stage Operations courses.
These are sections that are not found normally in our other courses.
And in our Stage Operations configuration initialization, that includes the LED panel
replacement demo and the color profile implementation for OCIO and 3D LUTs.
We'll also be covering live Stage Optimization using our Stage Operations tool execution
and optimization portion, but we're going to be looking at profile concepts overall
on that section and an overview of using Lumen and ICV effects and understanding LODs as
well as Nanite and virtual shadow maps overview.
Now, if you look at the IOT ICV effects program, the blended learning is a special
adjustment for this program.
And normally you're going to find that we have 13 scheduled courses in the Tier 1 program.
There are five additional classes coming for Tier 2 in late 2023 and those are still
under development.
Now normally most of the classes are in these sections highlighted here in orange.
The live hands-on classes for Stage Operations configuration and initialization and Stage
Operations DMX lighting and optimization.
Among those, the content that we are pulling from that is not covered in these sections
is actually going to be found in the recordings for these other classes seen here from our
virtual live classes.
So if you would like to find the information that is being left out from our normal
live hands-on classes, all of that is covered previously in the other sections.
It's just that the live hands-on classes goes back over those sections and gives
you a chance to actually walk through and try out all of these sections.
Now let's review the stage pre-flight checklist.
So in your review of your pre-flight checklist, you want to make sure you power up your
tracking solutions, your OptiTrack, a launch motive, and your update your volume calibration
as needed.
Power up your LED volume and pixel processor Brompton, layout your LED panel fixtures
and save configuration, camera hardware and connections, launch your source control Perforce.
Very important and point to workspaces and launch your UProject virtual set location.
Check all your needed plugins, that is very important, installed and enabled and
check and display configuration using your pre-built wall meshes, upload and sync changelist.
Launch your switchboard listener and make sure that you launch your switchboard overall
and connect to your pixel process software, your tesseract and sync changelist, build
your project partner only, and transact project to the wall.
Watch for gremlins.
That's it for this introduction into what you'll be viewing in our blended learning.
Thank you and enjoy those courses.